es gibt ja mehrere fragen die man sich
stellt wie laufen in ein szenario rhein
wo wir eventuell tatsächlich kein gas
mehr haben in ausreichendem maß in
diesem winter und vielleicht sogar im
nächsten winter je nachdem wie lange
diese krise dauert und das ist auch
absehbar wir werden nicht nur in der
industrie schwierigkeiten haben
arbeitsplätze sind in gefahr sondern
eben auch sag ich mal es steht zu
befürchten dass auch heizung abgestellt
werden müssen im ernstfall wenn eben
wirklich kein gas mehr in ausreichendem
maß da ist und da stellt man sich
natürlich die frage warum haben wir
trotzdem so ein klein klein in der
energiepolitik und ich frage mich auch
wie unser bundeswirtschaftsminister habe
sich hinstellen kann und sagen kann ja
wir wollen auf keinen fall die
atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen lassen wir
wollen auf keinen fall gas fördern in
deutschland was wir dringend brauchen
wir haben gas für 30 jahre in
deutschland wenn wir nur bereit sind das
zu fördern und wenn wir zum beispiel
auch bereit wären fracking zu betreiben
um eben dieses gas auch an die
oberfläche zu bringen und da muss man
sagen muss doch endlich mal schluss sein
mit diesen denkverboten und wir müssen
dahin kommen zu den lösungen und da
würde ich sagen fracking stadt frieren
ganz klar nach die fdp in der ampel zu
wenig druck die fdp machte ganze menge
druck und ich glaube wir haben auch in
diesen tagen sehr deutlich gemacht
selbst wenn man der kernenergie kritisch
gegenübersteht was viele auch in der
deutschen gesellschaft muss man sagen
auch tun und auch durchaus sage ich mal
mit bedenken die man nachvollziehen kann
dann muss man doch sehen wir sind in
einer notlage und wenn man in einer
notlage ist dann muss man auch mal über
seinen ideologischen schatten springen
und da meine ich wäre es jetzt an der
zeit dass die grünen auch sage ich mal
zumindest sei für einen
übergangszeitraum da auf eine andere
gedanken kommt und das hat die fdp auch
in der koalition ganz klar gemacht wir
sagen dass jetzt auch ganz klar bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen weil die fdp gut
man hat ganz klar die handschrift
gesehen jetzt heißt es aber oder wird
geraunt in berlin das ist zwischen den
grünen und der fdp 10 nicht knallt wie
wahrscheinlich ist denn dass die fdp auf
bundesebene sich mit den grünen einigen
wird wir haben uns bis jetzt immer
geeinigt das ist ja die positive seite
an der ganzen geschichte die die
regierungen arbeitet auch sie ist auch
sage ich mal in der umsetzung von vielen
vorhaben die wir hatten aber aus dem
koalitionsvertrag erfolgreich das
problem ist natürlich wir haben einige
dinge insbesondere natürlich die
aktuelle energiekrise die man nicht
vorhersehen konnte deswegen stehen aus
meiner sicht jetzt dinge im
koalitionsvertrag die auf diese krise
eben überhaupt nicht abheben konnten
weil man ja nicht wusste als man den
koalitionsvertrag abgeschlossen und
deswegen müsste man aus meiner sicht
jetzt an dieser stelle eben auch sagen
nein das ist nicht gut gelaufen und ich
hoffe sehr über nach die atomkraftwerke
verlängern ich würde auf jeden fall ein
meiler die nach da drei meiler die da
sind müssten jetzt in den streck betrieb
gehen das heißt also dass wir zumindest
die brennelemente die da drin sind so
lange fahren wie nur irgend möglich dazu
müsste es dann natürlich eine
haftungsübernahme geben des staates ist
falls sie betreiber das nicht weiter
wollen aber das müssten wir dann tun im
interesse eben dessen dass wir nicht
mehr gas verstromen müssen momentan für
strom wir auch heute wieder zwischen 4
und 9 gigawatt an gas einfach um strom
zu produzieren ein absoluter irrsinn
obwohl wir heute zum beispiel super
sonnentag haben fabelhafte werte was was
sonnenenergie angeht wind war heute
nicht so toll aber dann verstromen wie
kostbares gas statt das einzulagern für
eben den winter und das darf sich
einfach nicht intensivieren deswegen ist
für mich ganz klar wir brauchen einfach
jetzt neue ansätze und wir müssen gucken
dass wir da wirklich vorwärts kommen
endlagern hat sich das ist jetzt
überzeugt haben sie jetzt keine angst
mehr vor dem winter die fdp weiß regeln
oder ihr glaube ich nicht glaube ich
glaube dass da viel viel herum gewischt
wird viel augenwischerei betrieben wird
jetzt nicht sie persönlich aber ich
glaube in der bundesregierung hat
speziell
ich weiss es nicht ist wird sich zeigen
wo man mit des tages muss der mensch
irgendwie mit an denn ich glaube dass
wir nicht viel einfluss haben was meinen
sie mit der augenwischerei
ich glaube ist weg naja ich finde ich
finde auch die vergangenheit mit corona
und auch die flüchtlingswelle zuvor 215
da wurde viel vieles geredet vieles
versprochen vieles wurde nicht geändert
man hat es dann
er hat es ja auch angesprochen von der
polizei dass der mann hat man wusste 215
wie es abgelaufen ist machen wir das
jetzt wiederum genauso mehr oder weniger
es wird einfach da wird geredet man ein
wildes machen es gibt prozesse die
irgendein geleitet werden dass wir
trotzdem nicht vollzogen von daher ich
habe da so ein bisschen glauben an die
politik grundsätzlich verloren muss ich
ehrlich sagen weil da einfach vieles
auch einfach nicht umgesetzt wird was
dann versprochen wird oder es wird dann
wieder nach dem wahlkampf wieder
umgeworfen damit es wieder doch
revidiert und man muss dem kompromiss
eingehen wo ich nicht okay man muss ja
irgendwie mal standhaft sein in seinen
alten in seiner in seiner ist eine
ideologie will ich jetzt auch mal sagen
oder was auch immer und ja und auch
einfach mal durchziehen wenn man sagt
wir machen es jetzt oder machen das
jetzt so und wir müssen uns da jetzt mit
anpassen und dann ist das halt macht der
verdi strich kite wenn man drei
koalitionspartner
und fdp und grüne wollen nicht immer
dasselbe klar hätte ja ganz glauben sie
denn auch an die politik
selbstverständlich glaube ich noch an
die politik
ich glaube an die politik ob ich jetzt
jede politische richtung
befürworte und glaubt jetzt mal ja jetzt
mal
ich verknüpft dass man mit so einem
kleinen polizeilichen anreiz also wenn
wir ein polizeilicher einsätze gehen
dann verlassen wir uns immer auf das was
wir haben wenn der reserven bilden
können sorgen alter führungsgrundsätze
ist das gut aber nicht schlimm es nicht
können weil wir haben das was wir haben
wenn wir in deutschland
strom gewinnen können aus windenergie
strom gewinnen können aus solarenergie
kohle haben also steinkohle und
braunkohle und
wie sie sagen auch noch gas haben in
deutschland dann stellt sich für mich
die frage warum arbeiten wir nicht also
seit wenigstens vier wochen mit
allergrössten hochdruck daran unsere
eigenen reserven die wir ja haben ich
habe gerade beschrieben jetzt endlich
nutzbar zu machen warum warum und das
ist das was ich nicht verstehe versucht
man immer noch irgendwo mit anderen
staaten sich wiederum abhängig machen
von energie lieferungen wenn wir es gar
nicht nötig haben das ist mein das ist
mein punkt und da würde ich mir wünschen
egal welche egal welche partei und egal
ob regierungskoalition oder auch
position dass man sich da jetzt endlich
mal an einen tisch setzt und genau die
gedanken und zwar ohne gedanken bremse x
voran treibt natürlich haben wir
atomkraftwerke wir haben auf welche
stillgelegt ich verstehe ganz
persönliches meiner auffassung nicht
warum wir nicht ein atomkraftwerk noch
mal wieder noch mal wieder aktivieren
jetzt nicht von samoa technisch muss man
sagen ja wir könnten zum beispiel drei
die noch laufen länger laufen lassen wir
können sie länger laufen lassen wir
können auch wieder welche aktivieren
wenn man den energie betreibern die wir
damals dazu genötigt haben die dinger
stillzulegen gespräche führen um da auch
mal wieder mal wieder
und notfalls und notfalls muss das
fernziel seien in deutschland wie es in
einigen skandinavischen ländern ja auch
ist dass wir die hauptsache im winter
mit strom heizen wenn wir ihn denn
selbst produzieren können in deutschland
gar nicht so schwer sein muss ich nicht
politikwissenschaftlicher sein um
dahinter zu kommen sagte ich jetzt
eintragen